take a look at the man on the mound
patrick sandoval look
three starts overall this year and you
can see what he did in his last start
against oakland it was five shot out
2.57 gooby in three starts this season
yeah i like the way he's attacking the
strike zone his fastball has been
touching even 97 miles an hour we know
his change up is really really good
slider i think is he needs that as well
got him to swing right over the top of a
slider upper tier of the zone but nice
tilt in the end
he gets a good spin rate usually with a
slider even though it's not down and in
slow roller this might work
it does
first and third one out
the new bat in play and he gets a
swinging bunt base hit
it's a good situation for kyle seeger
and the mariners first and third was
just the one out third hit on the road
trip would come in handy here for sigs
goes the other way
line drive that's caught by upton
that'll play to run
productive out one-nothing mariners
seeger's 35th run bedded in
getting the start here this afternoon
coming up pretty good outing overall
this will be his fifth start 0-2 record
of 5-9-4 e-r-a 16-2 thirds he has 16
strikeouts only three walks for logan
gilbert
veteran justin upton
and jay up goes to town it's a fly ball
take a ride on that one upton with a
blast again
jay uptown funk going yard first fast
ball he sees
13th home run
loving that lead all spot
swinging bunt got the third six brought
him in
2-2
up the middle
and just with the doctor order takes
bayfield right to the bag 1-1 game as we
go to the second
right by him there's that kind of start
you were looking for gooby good fast
well that's three strikeouts for the
left-hander it's a 95-mile an hour
fastball
jamel just did exactly what jose was
talking about but he lifts it in the air
rendon boy did he fight that son nice
job by anthony
he doesn't stress a whole lot but there
was a little bit of stress on him going
for that pop-up
when that front hip opens up it's a
hitter and that front shoulder will and
it's difficult to have a good swing same
thing as a pitcher
big time change up disappeared at home
play that was a good swift inning
right to jake payne and he escapes in
the second leave him loaded one one game
donovan walton going to lead things off
the bottom of the lineup has done some
damage
well he turns on this rides it a long
way hits the pole that's a home run
donovan walton who's second big league
home run as he leads off the third 2-1
mariners
kyle seeger counter for the mariners
first run
and he'll get it done again with a base
hit meredith's lead now at 3-1 kyle
seeger two rbis today 36 for the season
popped it up
be the second baseman jack mayfield a
one two three third three one mariners
boy those are three really wicked
pitches in a row that's probably the
best slider he's thrown today and he's
got a good one when he stays on top and
staying away against trimel
undrafted even if you played at a place
like oklahoma to make it like mayfield
did great story good graphic there he
goes down on strikes back to back really
good arm action with his change up
you know he knows what walton did jose
as he fires a fast ball hit on a hop
back to the mound
don't give up the baseball yet left
hander this team may have a comeback in
them they're down three to one
[Music]
and murph got a good rhythm working
right now
one two
now the strikeout his third one down in
the fourth inning yeah on the slider in
the third inning that was a big pitch
for him started to find it
and another to that tally
four strikeouts
back to back caves and three
the last five that he's faced
there we go 3-2
runners go pitch swaying in a messy
struck a mouth
big time escape by logan gilbert 3-1
mariners
breaking ball ground ball bare-handed
play wow
they recall sandoval was a football
player at missing viejo high school
playing a football type play on that one
especially up and away
wow stubborn with the change up down and
away that's eight strikeouts for the
left-hander
on the ground goes right up the mound
fletch is there back behind the second
base bag that's 82 pitches
let's see if he has a chance to stay in
this game
got him
big strikeout
lead off
home run by upton the next hit came two
outs and the fourth to double the
fletcher
and that's a great way a crispy way a
dominant way to finish off the fifth
inning his seventh strikeout as he goes
one two three in the fifth
on the case chagua
outstanding one two three in the six
mariners
up by a deuce
beat him in
slider
unbelievable play by iglesias
wow
that's something you have to practice on
that flip with the glove you could speed
it second with what we got jp crawford
ryan hard right failed another rbi for
jp as walton scores
crawford
cruising in the second with an rbi
double his second double today and
americans have a 4-1 lead
jared walked in the first inning and
struck out a couple of times beyond that
he rolls it that's a fair ball skips
toward the corner
brandon they're gonna send him on around
the relay to the plate the slide in
there
jared walsh
brings the angels one step closer
big pitch in 1-1
to the right side mayfield
for the out the mariners escape again
angels have stranded nine we go to the
ninth and america's lead at four to two
ball four bears will take that
rbi for walton on a bases loaded walk
[Applause]
the lead goes to five to two
still an opportunity to break this thing
open crawford has been hot had a great
series
that'll pick up a run
deep flat ball plenty deep to score
tremel 6-2 mariners great job by j.p
crop
slow roller
throw to the plate
safe at first
score that was not a force in the second
and third he scores 7-2
hit it hard
through the six hole to get the force no
another run scored eight two mariners
base hit for the murph
justin upton it's a high fly ball toward
the alley in left center field it's down
and up against the wall fletch scores
easily jay up with a double and an rbi
rendon
toward the wall
off the base of it
one angel scores anthony into second
with the double
just knocking one little brick out of
the wall at a time
[Applause]
bouncing ball takes a high sunday hop
plates another run but it's a big second
out 9-5
[Applause]
got him
that is your ball game and the meredith
get a split in this series